Speaker 1: So I just spoke about how Mitch
McConnell told reporters he. Doesn't like
Republicans chances at winning the Senate in
2022 because Senate races have a lot to do with
candidate quality. Sort of alluding to the fact
that he doesn't think a lot of these Republican
candidates are high quality candidates and are a
little bit too out there to win these elections.
Let's take a look again at the clip as a reminder.
Speaker 4: I think there's probably a greater
likelihood the House, the Senate, Senate
races are just different. Their statewide
candidate quality has a
lot to do with the outcome.
Speaker 1: Well, another person, in addition to
Sean HANNITY, who is furious with McConnell's
comments, here is Donald Trump, who, of course,
has a vested interest in the outcome of the 2022
midterms, because he needs to see this big red
wave with as many of his candidates winning as
possible in order to feed into the narrative
that you need Trump as the figurehead of the
Republican Party if you want to win back the White
House in 2024. So Trump made a statement on truth
social bashing McConnell, which isn't all that
new, really. Trump has been treating McConnell
as a pinata for years now, but he even went so far
as to bring McConnell's wife into the mix and call
her crazy. Trump said, quote, Why do Republican
senators allow a broken down hack politician
Mitch McConnell to openly disparage hardworking
Republican candidates for the United States
Senate? This is such an affront to honor and to
leadership. He should spend more time and money
helping them get elected and less time helping
his crazy wife and family get rich on China. So
I believe that what Donald Trump is doing here is
setting the groundwork in place to have something
else to blame the 2022 midterm defeats on in the
event that his candidates lose their respective
races. And he really just has so many built in
excuses at this point. Like if an anti Trumper
were a half Trump supporting candidate loses their
race, well, he can just jump in and say that's
because they were against me. They were not a true
pro-Trump candidate, and that's exactly why they
lost. If you have a pro-Trump but doesn't want
to talk about him too much type of candidate,
someone like a Dr. Oz, for example, and they
lose will Trump could jump in and say, Well,
that's because they weren't embracing me enough,
right? I tried to do a rally in their home state
and they turned me down. If they had embraced
me more clearly, they would have won. And then
in this sort of situation, if you have someone
who is a full on pro-Trump supporting candidate,
where those excuses that I laid out previously
wouldn't work, now he can just blame Mitch
McConnell. He can say that, well, Mitch didn't
believe in the candidate and the NRC, the National
Republican Senatorial Committee. They didn't
spent enough on their race. And that's exactly
why they lost. It has nothing to do with me. And
then the all of the above excuse he can always
use is that there was voter fraud. So you always
had that one in your back pocket, too. That's a
favorite among Republicans these days. And then
the second interesting thing about this post by
Trump is the choice to go after Mitch McConnell's
wife, who is Elaine Chao? Chao worked in Trump's
cabinet. She was his transportation secretary,
and she actually resigned in protest after the
January six Capitol riots. So apparently that's
what got her on Trump's bad side. And that's why
Trump sees her as crazy now. And you got to wonder
how Mitch McConnell is going to respond to this,
if he's going to say anything about it at
all. Because we know that McConnell has been
very wishy washy about Trump in recent years. He
clearly doesn't like Trump. He doesn't like the
power that Trump has over him and the rest of the
Republican Party. But at the same time, he knows
that his Kentucky constituents like Trump, and
he knows that if he wants to remain in charge of
the Republicans in the Senate, he still has to at
least give lip service to Trump being in charge of
everything, and because otherwise they'll decide
to oust him as the minority leader. And so he's
in this horrible position of having to maybe
defend the person who just insulted his wife.
It's exactly what Ted Cruz had to face a couple
of years ago, where Trump called Cruz's wife
ugly. And despite how humiliating it was, Cruz
eventually had to come around and defend Trump,
backed him, support him, phone bank for him,
and just become a normal Trumpist. So we'll
see if Mitch McConnell decides to go the Ted Cruz
route or fill out a little bit more courage and
decide to stand up for his wife. What a incredible
situation that Mitch McConnell finds himself in.
And clearly, Trump hasn't learned his lesson
that you shouldn't go after people, spouses,
because why would he, Ted Cruz, let him get away
with it? So maybe Mitch McConnell will, too. And
will this lead to McConnell being more aggressive
against Trump? I'm not going to hold my breath.